the jurogan experience you know einstein
made three
three big mistakes at the end of his
career in the 1930s
he argued that black holes don't exist
gravitational waves don't exist
and quantum mechanics doesn't have
spooky action at the distance
you know he argued all these three
things at the end of his career when he
was the most experienced you know
and he was wrong we have experimental
data that shows that he was wrong on all
three
and what is the lesson from that even
the smartest person
you know that was last century in
physics
can be wrong if he works on the frontier
because you never know exactly
where the truth lies okay you have to
take risks
and if people want to just demonstrate
that they are smart
it's better not to take risks and how do
you not take risks
if you work on ideas that will never be
tested against
data against evidence so if you work on
super string theory or on extra
dimensions or on the multiverse
you can do intellectual gymnastics and
impress your colleagues that you're
smart
and you will get jobs you will get
recognition
you will get awards if that's your goal
that's a completely legitimate
framework but i see it as
a violation of our commitment as
physicists to understand nature you know
it's not really about
us physics is a dialogue with nature you
listen to nature
you see what the experiments are telling
you and you learn
and perhaps you are wrong you take risks
it's not about your image it's not
getting more likes on twitter so that's
why i don't really care
what my colleagues say if this object
looked unusual
i just talked about it the way i would
talk about any other anomaly
and people were asking you know why
isn't he backing down well i will back
down as soon as there is evidence
you know if i saw a photograph showing
that it's a rock or if i saw some other
objects like it
that we definitely have clear evidence
that they are naturally produced
then i will give up on it like and i'm
not afraid of being wrong you know
that's
that's part of any work on the frontiers
this is my thoughts on the the quantum
physics aspect of this
i think there's not enough people that
understand what they're doing
to criticize them so there's no social
pressure the difference between that
and the concept of exploring
extraterrestrial life is
extraterrestrial life is inexorably
connected to nonsense
it's an actually collected it's
connected to crazy people
they think that they're talking to
aliens
they're channeling people i have an
answer to that
okay suppose there was a whole
literature on covet 19
that is completely fictitious you know
like people were saying
crazy things about kobe 19 that make no
sense whatsoever and there was
you could find them yeah suppose there
were there were books about it
there were films about it now would that
mean that scientists
reputable scientists should not work on
a vaccine
for no no no but that's who there are
people that say nonsense you don't care
you ignore them
covet 19 is a real thing you can prove
it in a lab quickly
instantly i mean it's it's universally
acknowledged as being a real thing
right the problem with extraterrestrial
life is there's no evidence that it's
real well but if you step on the grass
and and you say look it doesn't grow
then obviously because you're stepping
on it
so if you bully anyone that works on the
subject then young people don't enter
into this
research field if you don't fund it at
all you dry it up
then there will not be discoveries
i step on the grass and it doesn't grow
therefore
there is no point in continuing to wait
for it you know to grow
i agree with you no i i think it's a i
think it's a
side effect of our social interactions
and i think a lot of professors a lot of
people in academia
they come from you know maybe a so
more socially awkward environment they
come from
a a lot of people that get into teaching
a lot of people that get into being
professors
they weren't like the class king they
weren't like the most popular person
and social interactions with them uh you
know maybe they were bullied maybe that
like
dr carl hart who's an academic was on a
couple days ago
was actually talking about this very
subject and that a lot of academics
they uh they see they try to undermine
other people's work
and they they do so in kind of a
bullying fashion yeah because it's all
about the ego you see
i was asked by the harvard gazette the
harvard university gazette which is the
pravda
of harvard you know this official
newspaper they asked me
uh what is the one thing you would like
to change about the world
you know a very big question yeah so i
wrote an essay i said
i want my colleagues to behave more like
kids
because as a kid i remember that you
know i was mostly curious about the
world i
i would not be afraid of making mistakes
i wasn't worried about my
ego or my something really strange
uh happens to those kids that take risks
and are not
worried about themselves so much uh
something
bad happens to them when they become
tenured professors in academia
tenure is supposed to give you the
freedom to explore
you know directions that might may turn
out to be wrong
you know that's what einstein
demonstrated at the end of his career
so you would expect people to take
advantage of that but instead
once professors become tenured for life
meaning that there is no risk to their
job
they are starting to pursue honors
and rewards status recognition yeah
they are afraid of making mistakes they
build these echo
chambers where they have students and
postdocs repeating their mantras
so that their voice will sound louder
so that they will get even more
recognition now i say
this you know the scientific inquiry is
not about us
it's about the dialogue with nature
trying to figure out what
nature is it's not about elevating our
status our image you know we will all
die in several decades so
you know it's really not that now
you know actually lex friedman was
asking me
avi you know so much uh what do you
think is the meaning of
life
and i told him look um i don't i think
we just exist you know any meaning that
we assign now
uh will go away in a billion years
because the sun
will boil off the oceans on earth there
will be no life on earth you know
all of these things that we call meaning
they are really temporary in the big
big we should just enjoy the process
just like eating good food
you know i would not mention another
example
uh you know doing these like eating good
food
you enjoy the process so learning about
the world figuring out what the world
is is very enjoyable you know i i
if i realized something nobody else did
and understand something that nobody
else did
it gives me pleasure so just the process
of doing that that gives me meaning
because i enjoy it you know so you
should live your life in a way that you
enjoy it if you like good food that's
good enough
you know you can live your life just
eating you know that's what animals do
yes yeah right uh can have sex you can
do
all kinds but if you want a deeper
sort of satisfaction i think
understanding the world
is what humans are capable of doing and
and that's really
a deeper level of of enjoying life so to
speak
well there's a lot of examples of
professors going out on a limb being
incorrect and then being punished being
ridiculed losing their status in the
community or
even being correct but not having the
support of your peers
who turn on you and turn against you and
then it turns out ultimately they were
correct but there's very little
there's very little repercussions for
that and there's a
thing that happens with people and ideas
where they get
scared to take on something that could
easily make them look ridiculous
and the best example of that is
extraterrestrial life
yeah that is it's so easy to get
ridiculed for believing in it
it's like bigfoot and then
extraterrestrial life i want to change
that i say
this is a subject the scientific
community can address with scientific
tools okay with telescopes
let's discuss it the public is
interested you know let's forget about
the past and look for a better future
right
and my point is uh there are many
examples for unborn babies
you know in science where people were
ridiculed and
ideas were never pursued or delayed you
know
for example looking for planets around
other stars you know that was
something something that was suggested
in 1952
by an astronomer called otto struve who
said
if you take jupiter the planet jupiter
put it close to the sun
then it will move the sun back and forth
a lot
and you could tell if there is a close
in jupiter near
other stars by looking at their motion
or
looking as it occults the star comes in
front of it transits in front
he suggested that 1952 for four decades
astronomers ignored that why because
they said
we know that jupiter in our solar system
is far away
and we understand why it's far away and
therefore
we shouldn't waste our time even looking
for something like that
then in 1995
a couple of astronomers found a hot
jupiter jupiter close to a star
and then got the nobel prize a couple of
years ago for that
so my point is this is an example of a
baby that was eventually born
so people would say oh yeah science
works you see eventually
it was found my point is it took four
decades in those four decades you know
we could have done a lot
to advance science and
the other thing is i say okay this baby
was born but there might have been other
babies that were not born you know
ideas that were put forward and were
scrutinized for no good reason just
because people are close-minded
and you know the strange thing for me is
i see a lot of innovation in the
commercial sector you see
uh you know jeff bezos elon musk you
know apple
google they have
parts of their companies that is that
are doing
blue sky research you know things that
are not applied start
it all started with ibm and before that
and then in academia
i see a lot of conservatism much less
innovation as in the commercials
now the commercial sector is after
making a profit
you would expect academia to be even
more open-minded
but it's not and to me that has
that must change is this something that
you had as an idea before
publishing this this oh yeah these
thoughts about extraterrestrial life
and did that accentuate it for you yeah
yeah i didn't expect the response that i
received
it doesn't bother me um you know in my
uh i have a 800 more than 800 papers
that i published and
eight books in in in all of these
i talk about anomalies you know over the
years i talked about anomalies in other
contexts you know like in in the early
universe and
and um when i mentioned speculative
ideas
in other contexts there was no pushback
you know
it it it wasn't threatening to anyone it
wasn't
but something about the subject of
extraterrestrial life
bothers people and frankly you know i'm
just like a kid i try to be as close as
possible to the way i was
at a young age i'm just doing it
innocently working on this subject the
same way i work on other subjects
and i get this response that now the
only reason the two of us are speaking
you know and i get a lot of media
attention is because my colleagues are
not behaving the same way
if everyone would accept you know i
think it's common sense what is common
sense to me
if everyone would accept it i would be
no different than the person next to me
you wouldn't speak you wouldn't be
speaking to me sure i would no i still
would be
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience